hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to huniepop now I could
make some big [ __ ] excuse about why
I'm playing this again but it amounts to
nothing other than the fact there are
some lovely lovely virtual ladies in
this game or cats or aliens and I want
to concussed them all I want to conquer
them a note that sounds too mean and
scary
I want to seduce innate all of them and
then sleep do the dancers [ __ ] so my
objective in this playthrough is to be
able to sleep do sex now next up its me
sleazy about it even though now I'm even
sleazier than I was before I'm gonna do
the sex with every character that there
is and I need to unlock Momo and then
that's gonna be really weird and then
there's an alien yep there's an alien in
this game I don't know how to unlock her
but I'm gonna find out so here we go I
think okay bye Aiko hope you had a good
day oh let me to knees what was your
first time like with the girl of course
once I found the hole we were good to go
I don't like to brag but she came at
least three times short lived
what did she die is horrible mm-hmm yeah
you would know considering we just did
the sex but enough of that I go please
leave I need to continue thank you um so
who should be my next target wow I
couldn't be creepier if I wanted to I'm
really not trying to be very creepy okay
so I'll get Momo tomorrow or something
or as soon as the goldfish bag but
there's also a way to get who do I want
to go for next I do like belly
I think bellies are cutie
lo-lo's out of town Lola would be my
next choice Lola did much to impress me
in the last one with her personality her
incredible personality anyway let's go
for belly swing by the campus later and
keep me company oh don't you know I'm a
bang oh hey oh well I'll be doing will
you look at this guy
I hardly recognize you without the
virginity she congratulation her man and
with such a fine young impress haha I
think she was 28 but still that's
considered young I'm only 26 that was
nothing under tarted damn I am I'm the
least unstoppable hey I might even be a
little jealous I mean you've got a ways
to go but you're turning out to be a
regular sex machine a shame to let these
girls have you all since oh oh I can
flirt with you oh boy I don't know why
I'm so loudly excited about the cow like
its life with you
okay so this actually rings a bell
because someone said that I needed to
give her this the dirty magazine because
because because this is important I
don't know what about the tissue box I
don't know if she wants that too because
then she I know what I'm doing today
here you can have this thing whatever it
okay that the pierced have sanded okay
that is important because that summons
the alien I'm pretty sure the alien
she's very final but she's an alien
nonetheless an illegal alien of
invention yeah if we could just build a
wall round earth keep out those dirty
darn aliens like Superman [ __ ] super
bad so uh she likes I've also discovered
like I discovered a lot about this game
that when you buy the heart gifts you
get gifts in return and that's how
you're gonna be able to get a lot more
stuff than you would originally
so what bands I guess you never get
those just received a new present good
for me and then you take your present
your Boop and then you got hoop earrings
but I already have a very good set up of
stuff right now I've got three different
policies to get rid of broken heart so
I'm never gonna lose a game ever ever
ever again yes some of the basic what
basics when first meeting belly what was
my advice to you remember
oh she was on the beach and her boobies
were helps your boobies creepier
markiplier the creep where did you and I
first died at the bar or in lounge we're
at a bar right
you had brown hair I just played through
this kitchen nothing
yes you expectedness again how did I
tell you to open up your initial
interaction with Nicky Nicky which one's
Nicky again uh uh uh
that my weirdness might actually pay off
how can I forget I didn't forget you
just saw I didn't forget I never forget
okay I got to go I got to go cuz I'm
gonna say hi to belly oh she's at the
beach - okay so the thing might work on
the beach I'm pretty sure it's on the
beach I'm almost 100% positive it's
actually on the beach so if I use this
on the beach I'm gonna summon a big blue
alien her name is I forget but oh how
I've missed you belly excuse my spit
everywhere well with love and heed or
there's going to be love lots of okay so
if
I wouldn't know what to do with this I
hope you didn't go through much trouble
I only gave a dirty magazine to a fairy
don't worry about it it's only a weird
thing do you want a bagel nuts okay but
thank you for all do you want to use
tissue box really sorry I don't think I
would get much use out of it oh of
course not that's more of a meeting okay
so uh ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba how do
you feel about spirituality spirituality
it's the spiritualization estoy shop the
great love goddess that doesn't seem
right
100 percent burial but I don't leave
that Hey
as someone who practices yoga it's
probably clear rice okay I don't know
I've never yo good in my life you want
to go on a date she's like that lot she
wants to go on a date with me are you
gonna keep the bikini on balle balle
balle oh she's gonna keep the bikini on
bye-bye
I am just I'm a three-year-old who's so
excited about the wrong never mind let's
lose that comparison and then shut the
hell up life all right I'll be right
back I'm not gonna lose it's impossible
for me oh god yeah oh yeah yeah yeah you
did it I'm a success seriously wants you
because I restarted the game all the the
difficulty of the puzzles are actually
much lower now Tom and I have a much
better time I don't think I've ever
gonna fail one
which was a disgrace although after I
learned the game before I've already
learned the game twice now over here no
it was moderately not terrible okay
heard a Pelle how's it go in there okay
so if this doesn't go here I doubt I'm
supposed to throw it away because I got
it would be the same thing with the Momo
cuz you're supposed to throw away the
bag of fish with Momo oh I have no idea
oh well q then I go to King didn't deal
with Q I don't think I actually went on
the date with Q until next time okay
Baba Bailey I'll see you later
I'll see Billy later I'll see belly away
later Oh champ is doing great champ
can't believe how good Chandu I'll get
mad sick and blast chunks all over it's
gross
yeah that is gross why did you need to
describe to me look go on a day let's do
this let's do what [ __ ] excuse me how do
fairies date will anybody be able to see
you with me because you can turn
invisible
hey watch a classic dating sentence
people is it but what are you wearing
you're wearing leaves I know you're a
fairy but I mean come on this cliche is
getting a little too trubbish alright
fine oh I'm not for real stop that don't
be so mean to me damn I'm just not
getting set up for combos right now only
and the best even though I was very
close to losing that even though I'm
doing much better these days and I'm
very quality at the game of dating and
flirting and being sexy look at me in my
hot come hey
I've been playing douchebag games I know
how to get the ladies where's my viagra
or I mean steroids good Jesus I really
met what thermo anyway let me uh
now I'll figure the next episode I'll
figure out how to do the thing in the
next episode but I cou I've already been
with a go let's go see Tiffany I don't
think I gave Tiffany like the time of
day the last time then I played this
game so I'm gonna see what Tiffany's all
about definitely seems adorable also
Tiffany is the daughter of Jesse who is
the cam girl right now mine too can't
you see that I'm young and hip whoa I'm
so old what's shakin bacon is that with
the new kids say I don't know I don't
remember what I've asked you well that's
the same last name is Jesse no you
really can't see it all that well but
there's totally a sexy farrier in the
way but this is where I live what where
do you live what the hell is that I
don't know what is that in the clouds
are you cloud lady okay fine then all
right bye
uh let's go on a date you and I I'm good
at the dating yeah let's leave this
stupid Club and then go on a date and
then immediately come right back to the
club anything but the roller coaster I
am NOT getting on that thing why you
gonna describe how you're gonna park
like you did best
this is a no-brainer I am the greatest
name is markiplier and I am cruel and
good at games there we go got it didn't
even need combos even though it's not
giving me combos which is making me very
very worried because I'm supposedly very
good at this game and I don't want to
fail I get a good time
oh boy I could just jump in cheer cuz
I'm a cheer louder leader what I need to
see belly goodnight goodnight whatever
don't let the penis bite oh god shut up
mark God my belly has just made a
terrible terrible joke terrible joke but
I got a message from Tiffany shut your
face I need to look at this bestie took
this pic in class Oh panty shot your
bestie was sitting at the front of the
class crouching in front of your desk
what is this yandere simulator how did
you let her get away with that okay and
why would you send that to anybody
alright anyway why granite present I get
it present in mushrooms I guess I
measured for you they got $1400 you
better know what they do
really
I love things like ah I bet you do but
still no goddamn fish [ __ ] okay do I go
on a date or what let's date you and me
no one wants my baby not my food I
bought it for you or anybody literally
any woman take my bagel
please finals go on a date don't mess me
up this time I think I have anything
going on all right let's go well if
you're all so desperate to be in my
company why don't you give me more
reasons to not be happy about this this
this is dating they not love course not
love mam sentiment what it's only since
oh my poor girly gosh poor girls from
four seduced sis jakszyk Takei was being
seduced real but he's not
hey success I am good at this game I
knew I was good I had a funny feeling I
was good and this proves it I'm good I
hope we can go out like this again we'll
go out like this again no and don't you
worry about a thing little lady
we will go out like this again oh you
and I will be on so many dates just you
wait
it's gonna be good all right so I gotta
figure out before this episode ends I
want to figure out how to summon the
blue alien huniepop blue aliens summon
how to guide walkthrough duty pop let's
see okay I found this on the web for
booty pop blue alien summon how to guide
walkthrough that didn't help me at all
okay I was right I needed to take it to
the beach but I was wrong at the time I
need to take it to the beach tonight so
I need to get to the beach sometime
tonight and then I'll be able to do so
any day I guess I could go on another
day under way sure is let's go go get
him don't mind me I'm gonna flirt with
every girl I see and it just so happens
they're only like 12 girls in this
entire place what I play the play oh you
do know mmm I can't believe I'm actually
sending this do not let anybody else see
this is for your eyes I'd only Matt get
ready with the censorship oh wow okay
Matt censored but dang Thank You belly
yeah I am so creepy right aren't I
literally creepiest creep I could ever
creep I'm gonna move away from this page
now that's for my eyes only not for the
million people out there watching hey
stop it now don't do things
I don't know what you'd be doing so
dutiful uh-huh okay bye I gotta go
Nola's back oh no wait that oh it's
night now it's night now okay I have to
do something of significance in this
episode or else it won't
this won't be a good return so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna summon the blue
alien and then the next episode I must
start you know you know you know you
know get a little uh yes speech ha ha ha
all right we're gonna get this we're
gonna do this this is what I set out to
do so I've gotta go it can't wait oh
shut up I'm not here for you I'm here
for this you want this I really have no
use for this don't you sorry
well son goodbye goodbye okay cool maybe
I'll see you tomorrow
yes hold it right there
damn straight I believe you have
something that belongs to Michigan like
it back oh you can have it there's a
critical component to my ships engine
how did you get that a fairy gave Tim he
it was he me I swear
state it I have no time for stories
no matter I'll be taking that back now
oh okay thank you
well your cooperation is appreciate your
action it would be wise for you to
forget this encounter ever happened oh
don't forget noogie bag
we don't even know your name actually I
do it's Celeste my name why what do you
want to know my name so ready this is
exactly the sexiest alien I've ever laid
eyes on oh you really think I'm a
trapped I sure do I suppose you're not
terribly hideous Cory yeah well boy this
goes against my better judgment not to
mention that that that it's strictly
against brother I often go against
people's business I'm stranded here I
may as well try to enjoy myself wait
your luck fibers greatest lover I was
taught by a fairy who is great right
Yolo okay well in your case anyway oh
right then you just earned yourself a
new friend my name is Sergei arsonist if
you'd like to come and see me try to
find me later in the day my people are
nocturnal besides it's too risky to be
walking around in broad daylight
something tells me that people wouldn't
really mind hello hey just how
intelligent are you yes sure intelligent
star is your planet Sun it's the yellow
one yellow dwarf what's gonna be a red
supergiant I don't think it's a dwarf
yet but it's gonna turn into eight
you're smarter than I thought he asked
me about space I know all about space
I'm the face man
so I hope you're prepared I'm so
prepared what is the largest planet in
your soldiers Jupiter not stupid to
Jupiter's that is correct
thank you okay all right so I unlocked
the blue alien by the name of Celeste so
in the next episode I'll take her on a
lovely date mr. flirting with a cat
won't that be exciting anyway so in the
next episodes I'm gonna try to get
up.get with one girl every episode I
didn't do this one but he made a lot of
progress so thank you everybody so much
for watching I am going to play this
game to completion and it's going to be
absolutely amazing for me and probably
three of you out there so thank you
three of you and as always I will see
you in the next video